Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr it's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 17th,
2018 how's it going?
How are you?
What's up with you?
Um,
how was your football Sunday?
I know what's going on with me.
I felt like I had a cold.
Now I don't know what I have.
And,
uh,
my wife's like,
well,
maybe you have allergies.
It's like,
I don't have allergies.
I've never had allergies in my life.
And she's just like,
well,
sometimes there's,
there's late onset allergies.
So she's got me thinking I have allergies.
I never,
you know,
I thought allergies for like,
people who had like inferior DNA,
you know,
just like weak people,
like the kind of puppy that the mother big knorrs and just let you die.
It doesn't let it,
let it get any milk,
you know?
But we're human beings and everybody's special.
So you keep these people going and then they just walk around constant state of
like,
you know,
listening to the nasally voices.
Oh my God.
Did somebody eat lobster in the last month?
And then you got to like fucking vaccinate your house,
whatever it is,
d fumigate your house because somebody with allergies comes by
know.
But evidently I'm one of those people,
you know,
my mom should have ignored me.
Who Knew?
Who knew I maybe I have late onset.
Who the fuck gets allergies at 50?
You what's funny about all your other nonmedical people out there right now?
What are you doing?
You listen to this podcast and now you're googling the shit,
right?
Everybody's just a dick to them.
I couldn't get the answer right now,
you know?
Do you ever,
do you ever consider the source,
not to mention the,
the,
the fucking guy who's a,
you know,
looking for the information,
being you not having a fucking medical degree.
All of a sudden you're,
you're like some doctor.
I do it all the time.
That's why I got a nutritionist because I was trying to learn about food.
I just couldn't figure it out.
And everybody just,
you know,
at a conflicting opinion,
it was like this Guy Damn,
uh,
feminists and uh,
the guys with the date rape drug,
they just can't seem to get on the same page.
No,
it's like Democrats,
Republicans,
you know what I mean?
They all agree on what the problems are.
They just sitting there pointing fingers at each other.
These fucking people in,
in the food industry,
it's the same thing.
You know,
I got the fucking giants cowboys game on and there's some fucking asshole.
He literally is sitting on the field at a little too top table.
How much of those tickets,
these guys are running around fucking smashing their brains out,
right?
And that's an incomplete pass.
And they,
the guy puts his hands up like,
where's the flag sitting there?
Like fucking Julius.
What does he see?
A high ranking official at that,
the,
the Home Depot corporate office.
You mentioned like the jobs that we have nowadays.
Can you fucking imagine if you just met people from the past and they're just
looking at you like you do what,
what do you do?
And we'd all be saying this shit.
And then just be like,
they would all be just looking at it.
You don't do anything
and your wife does.
She was like,
the whole fucking nothing would make sense.
You know?
I wonder if it's going to be like in a hundred years,
like we can actually,
you know,
if we were still around a couple of hundred years,
we could just fucking look down on people and what their jobs are because robots
are now fucking,
I dunno,
entering data.
I Dunno people.
I don't pretend to understand.
But how did you guys in shambles your second week of football?
Mine was a,
you know,
I mean,
we lost,
it wasn't that big a deal though.
Everyone's gonna make a big deal.
I know.
Edelman's not back yet.
The second week of the fucking season,
you know,
you know what?
What do you,
what do you know?
Why?
What the fuck you can't go fucking Jacksonville.
They're all going to be fucking freaking out.
Oh my God,
we finally beat the Patriots.
Does this mean we win the Super Bowl?
Right?
That's what everybody does.
Everybody gets all fucking excited.
Like,
you know,
when you watch an action movie,
you know the Rambo Guy,
is he freaking out now the Chuck Norris Freak out.
Now,
you know,
freaks out the guy who's going to fucking die that suits everybody.
Relax.
You know,
jets fans.
How many times are you going to get the ego to let the Lazy New York sports
media fucking gas up another guy?
All right.
He said to fucking solid weeks.
He's gone.
One and one.
He's throwing for 300 yards.
Whatever.
Fucking uh,
both weeks.
Very impressive.
You know,
but you don't become a legend in September.
I know you're hopeful.
I mean,
even the firemen came back.
What?
Where did he come back?
You guys were such conch.
You know what the fuck is wrong?
The jet fans steed,
they chased a fireman.
How long have you cursed for post nine 11 in New York,
you chased a fireman out of your own fucking stadium and you got the balls to
think that a couple of decent weeks of football.
Then all of a sudden you're walking down the street talking to the camera,
talk,
calling out Tom Brady,
Tom Brady,
the man,
you guys all we all wanted to be Tom Brady.
We all want to be good looking be the quarterback barriers supermodel.
Have a nice fucking dimple in our chin.
Full head of fucking hair.
Mary and I already said that part right?
Fucking white.
When five fucking super bowls,
get a respectful fucking nod from Montana's.
You're putting on your yellow fucking jacket,
right?
We all wanted that.
All right,
well guess what?
Despite all these fucking Instagram accounts out there that are telling you,
you can do a then you want everybody's fucking specially reality is there's only
one Tom Brady.
All right,
so are you green couch down there?
I'm happy for you.
I'm happy that you're excited,
but you might want to reel it in a little bit.
You know you have to have a friend of yours every time he fucking made to check.
He thinks that's the one
you know and you just go lock.
I'm about to pick this guy up off the fucking Matt again.
How many times can I sit across from,
you should cry it and you fucking beer.
All right.
What are you just going to fuck a broad and move on?
That's the problem.
These jets fans,
they're fucking romantics.
Oh,
they fell as he live right there.
Let's see.
I know.
Thrown for a touchdown with a minute.
I have left too little too late.
You know,
they probably let them go right down the field.
Okay.
I love listening to spa.
People flip out this time of year.
You know I'm,
I'm actually,
okay.
I'm taping this Sunday night.
All right.
I'm going to predict.
Let me just get to go around the league.
Look at the scores here,
and I'm going to predict the fucking overhyping me with my fucking 50 year old
allergies.
I have allergies.
I can't,
there's no Fido.
I won't allow it.
Very have a varicose vein.
I can't,
I can't fucking compound that with an allergy.
MMM.
Anyways,
when I had it right here,
I had the NFL scores,
didn't I?
Isn't that what happened now?
Now why wouldn't you go for two there
then you're really doubt by nine.
That's just three.
Three drives with three field goals you could get back in.
This came with the mid 28 left and we each got to.
How are you gonna have to fucking questions to answer after this game by people
who never got picked in gym class.
MMM.
All right,
let's go around the league.
Here we go.
The scores here.
All right.
This is what,
this is what my predictions are going to be.
All right.
The chiefs I made,
I'll tell you right now,
I see a lot of people the duly,
what does Patrick,
my home age,
however you say his new homes.
I mean dish guy.
If he keeps this shop
kg shitty will be undefeated.
Yeah,
they were.
When you first Superbowl Superbowl for
Ed Patrick Coho days is going to have the greatest season ever read the history
of the NFL.
I do have to tell you though,
if Patrick,
my homeys what my homes was fucking doing this shit for the jets or anywhere in
New York.
Good Lord,
they would have declared a fucking state of emergency on side.
Kick the giants.
Get the ball.
Look at this.
Here we go cowboys ago.
There's still not enough.
I can time lift.
Um,
but this is when you as a gambling man,
you like,
this is fucking fixed,
right?
Flipping out.
Although I think the jokes were favored by wrong.
I have no idea.
Um,
okay.
They're going to fucking sit there and freak the fuck out.
Uh,
Ryan Fitzpatrick,
I obeyed your pocket.
Is Jesus fucking Christ?
Get to it.
Oh,
the first job since fucking 2014 is this going to be their year?
I don't know shit about anything at this point.
All I could say about the bucket ears is there too.
And Oh,
they've scored 75 points and they've led up 61.
All right.
40 of those fucking points where the goddamned sates.
So you know,
I dunno,
you know,
fucking wind games,
48 40 and shit like that in the,
uh,
in the playoffs.
So I would be relaxed with them.
You know who,
obviously the most impressive team in the league has gotta be the fucking ramps.
This scored 67 points and only let up 13.
I know they played the fucking Raiders day bucket.
They could day,
but they did what they were supposed to do.
They beat the shit out of him
after all locked Gloucester first fucking half a Jaguar's looked good though.
Good.
Anytime he got Tom Kaufland anywhere near it,
you're going to win.
They look good.
Uh,
patriots,
you know,
who knows.
I Dunno.
Maybe
we'll see.
We'll see what happens with Edelman comes back.
We had a couple of fucking injuries I don't believe are the dolphins,
even though they're 2.0 I feel bad for the bills.
Uh,
the chiefs,
God knows the chiefs,
the chiefs love nothing more than fucking fucking stroke and their fans,
it's September.
We'll the Fed's finally get to bust and not come play off time.
Or were they once again go home with fucking blue balls.
Okay.
Um,
what else?
I think that's fucking it.
Most of the little packers are,
I liked the packers.
I like the rims.
And then I liked the direction the Jaguars are going in and the chiefs,
I just too many fucking times they did it last year.
Everybody gets all fucking excited and
[inaudible] and the holidays come of log in right there.
They all start dressing up like fucking date of Americans,
you know,
the too much pumpkin bread and then the digit shit,
the bed and fucking November.
I have no idea.
And basically I'm judging the entire franchise and what they'd done in the past,
even though they probably have brand new personnel.
I still believe,
I still believe in John Ruetten
despite all these people that you get g g is it all Getty tied for concern?
I mean if they go,
only three is John Cruden on the hot seat.
See,
uh,
I know they were waiting all day today and then they lost in the end.
But this is a fucking franchise that has been fucking lost at sea for a long
time.
I've been impressed with John Cruden played a great,
they,
his team played a great first half against the best team in the league,
I think the fucking rams.
MMM.
Oh,
the most impressive teams so far.
And uh,
you know,
play damn good against the Broncos.
Not good enough,
long enough or whatever.
I still believe in this guy.
So they had today's my two sets.
There's my fucking white noise,
no pun intended to a lie goes DP,
ah,
and complete.
Um,
you know what they said when I was watching the Patriots game,
uh,
what's his face there?
Tony Robot,
another fucking gem.
Another gem.
Like he just like every,
it's like the psycho flying.
Every time you fly you learn something.
Right?
Every time you listen to a game it Tony Romo is,
is doing the color.
You fucking learned something.
He,
there was a guy in the Jaguars,
he had our guy beat,
Eddie was running along.
There was,
you know,
Burt along the sideline when to be call that fucking pattern and he was right on
the sideline and Tony said if he ran two yards more in like more towards the
field,
it's such an easier throw for the quarterback.
He said he actually ran the root wrong.
And I don't know if he got forced outside,
but just,
you know,
totally is also gonna sub side with the fucking quarterback.
But it was so fucking interesting.
Oh yeah.
Because then he can maybe throw to the outside of the shoulder.
That case still has a step or a step and a half to adjust to the ball.
If you just run right on the sideline,
the fucking guys like a half step behind you.
Now he has to throw a goddamn strike.
What is the Eli Manning and the the fucking last drive of a super bowl.
Uh,
all right,
enough of that fucking talk.
Uh,
it's still really early.
Um,
I called the my bookie people,
I pick the Jaguars.
MMM.
I talked to Paul Versey.
I picked the lions is lock of the week was San Francisco and I was like,
I don't think,
I don't think the fucking lines are as bad as that first game.
That's the thing when you shit the bed the first fucking week,
cause you gotta have a game where you just suck
when he is 60 games just going to come out flight.
You're just gonna fucking suck.
Right.
But when it happens the first week of the year,
everybody looks like it's just what they're going to do all year round you up
and we get you got you made your point.
All right.
Whatever.
MMM.
I picked the giants.
I'm going to lose this one and I had one other one I think I went to and one I
went to and one the first week with my book and I think it went to one this
week.
Um,
I call him in every week and call the sports gambling podcasts or not.
I give you my pics,
uh,
in my locker.
The week was that somebody was going to get fired for criticizing the,
the woman that did the play by play and I was fucking wrong.
I thought someone was going to do,
someone was going to fucking jump on that fish hook and that was going to be at,
um,
anyways,
congratulations to frank or passing Curtis Martin very quietly.
The guy's forth all time.
I don't know if you get to see too many more of these guys,
the way they fucking throw handoffs now.
Uh,
the only people in front of them now is Walter Payton,
Barry Sanders and I at Smith.
And I don't think anybody's ever going to catch em at the way the game has
changed.
Uh,
and that's it.
There you go.
There's my,
there's my fucking take all the whole fucking thing for this week.
All right.
How long,
how long did that burn up?
15 and a half minutes of your life that you never got to get back.
Um,
all right.
This weekend I am scheduled to be out in Virginia.
I think those gigs will be good.
Uh,
and then I'm in South Carolina.
I haven't been keeping up too much on the hurricane.
I just keep seeing.
Yeah.
I hate to see,
you know,
who the fuck wants to watch people losing their houses?
I don't get,
why do I want to watch that?
We'll save it.
Hurricane Florence,
hurricane Fitzpatrick,
hurricane flo Jo,
Hurricane Florence.
Florence wreaks havoc in north and South Carolina.
All right,
so Virginia's okay.
So I got two gigs there.
Now,
this is the hardest thing after a hurricane happens,
is who do you give your money to?
You know what I mean?
I do.
I make sure the money that I'm going to donate gets to the right fucking gets to
that person of seed on TV.
By the way,
you see all these people getting rescued,
all those old people,
people in wheelchairs,
fucking broke ass people.
That's what I was talking about.
People who do you get the fuck out of there?
A lot of them can't.
Lot of them can.
Um,
Oh man,
look at that.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Do you see that thing that Rogan fucking posted on uh,
Instagram?
Who that guy was,
he was doing this weird thing was he's trying to act like he was leaning into
the wind and it just didn't look real.
And then two people walk by in the background,
like totally normal.
I love when that fucking outfits the best.
Whatever's where the guy was in the boat and then people just walked by.
Uh,
and then what are you going to do with it at that point?
Is he gonna get out of the boat?
I like the camera man to how he zoomed into the gay,
tried to do a solid must be his drinking buddy or something like that.
Uh,
so anyways,
alright,
well,
Hurricane Florida,
hopefully,
uh,
the waters will recede at an event.
I don't want,
I don't know.
I got checked with my agent to see if the South Carolina was still going on.
Jesus Christ.
I wonder if those fucking bankers that main off all that fucking money offer
those people in that you'll watch them lose their house if there's even there.
You know,
there's not an ounce of fucking guilt too.
Yeah,
yeah.
You,
you did that.
If they don't give a fuck,
they don't give a fuck.
Here we are going after fucking isis where these fat fucking cons.
Who fucked everybody?
Their own countrymen.
At least isis has the decency to go after people that had that,
that aren't their own countrymen,
these fucking bankers that God,
they're committed treason.
I don't know much about the world,
but I believe if you did what they did here in Southeast Asia,
you get put to death.
What are those fucking countries?
Uh,
who the fuck is the coach of the giants?
Did they get rid of that fucking fat guy?
That guy who looked like they just took them out of the fucking mezzanine level.
Uh,
wait a second.
Did they get rid of that guy?
Giant's head coach.
All right,
let's see.
Oh,
he is.
Ah,
why does it always go to Wikipedia now?
All right.
Wait a second.
Tom carper that they had Bob Mcadoo,
Ben Mcadoo and they were like,
Ben Mecca,
don't get the fuck out of here.
Sorry.
Then Steve Spag a new low,
eh,
he was the interim coach and now they got pat show
that shoe,
it looks like a winter.
He would go there fucking open toe.
Gotta love it.
Older guy that keeps himself in shape,
you know,
now here he doesn't have fucking white hair.
I Dunno who he was.
I don't know who fucking guy was anyone's that's going to get on with the
podcast here.
Um,
I didn't do shit this week and I'm such a fucking weird weekend.
I thought I was going to be on the road and then Mother Nature Cape fucking
scream it in.
Is that going to be another hurricane behind this one?
Over that parade of horrors last year,
like fucking 20,
20 hurricanes that are rob spice feminist.
They'd get upset by that,
you know,
to constantly name them by women's names insinuates that we cause problems
in men's lives.
Um,
I don't even know what to fucking say.
No,
I actually did a Gig the other day.
I did a,
a benefit Thursday night the last time I was on stage and uh,
you know,
I gotta be honest.
It was one of these,
you know,
they had like a red carpet and all this shit and I was just,
I saw some of the people,
I was like,
Oh man,
I got go fucking Bob on this one.
It was the exact opposite.
That's like one of the hardest I've ever gone on stage and recent fucking memory
as far as like,
fuck it,
I'm going to say this fucking,
I'm going to say that.
And it went great and everybody was flipping out.
Fuck it.
Enjoying it.
Laughing
budget.
Women came up to be meaning for saying how fun did they thought it was.
And I gotta be honest with you,
I think the same way
the mass media misread this last election,
they are misreading
where like people's idea of what is funny and what isn't.
Because I was in Hollywood people,
liberal ground,
fucking zero and all those jokes killed and everybody thought it was funny and I
was sitting there,
you know,
after every other fucking,
yeah.
Was that the one that's gonna to get me in trouble?
Is this the fucking [inaudible]?
Am I going to have to fucking,
you know,
it's fucking unbelievable now.
Yeah.
Like you can't even have like an opinion.
That's what kills me is that that you did something.
If you just have an opinion that does not agree with them,
then all of a sudden you have to go on TV and you have to fucking apologize.
I,
I don't,
I don't know.
This is it.
I really feel that they're going to make a movie about this era.
It,
it's going to be like,
uh,
the red scare.
Like McCarthyism meets like fucking my space or something.
Who's going to be in it?
You know,
whether they should.
People consider how many more innocent men are we gonna let suffer?
Well,
don't try to say you can't say anything.
Oh my God.
What is this guy wearing?
His wearing a fucking sports bra.
I am watching the Dallas cowboys right now in this guy just came out wearing a
fucking,
I have shirt slash sports bra from the fucking 1980s.
Did he steal that from one of the cheerleaders?
It's not even a half shirt.
He's,
it's a bra.
He's covering his,
his mail.
Pictorials yeah.
MMM.
There's
Zubin Way Zach Prescott.
Right.
And then you know what's going to happen.
There's gotta be a bunch of people who,
uh,
like to wear a male sports bras that are going to be offended.
It'd be like,
why did you zoom in on his madly beard when you could've showed this other guy
who's essentially dressed like a spice girl?
Oh my God.
Ah,
God bless them.
I'd love to be that fucking ripped.
I don't know if there was ever a point in my life,
I could fucking pull off what this guy's pulling off.
Holy fucking shit.
Oh my God.
God bless him.
Uh,
anyways,
I really am old.
I'm an old man now.
Christ.
What are these kids where it,
you know,
I actually,
I should be in full support of this cause we wore have shirts in the 80s.
I never had the nerve to where one outside of the house.
Um,
yeah,
no,
I was just too pasty.
I never thought I had fucking abs enough to do it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And uh,
I didn't,
you know,
a few things I never thought would come back half shirts and fucking Larry Bird
short shorts and they are back with the fucking vengeance.
MMM.
It really is.
Does anybody look worse than a fucking football helmet?
They need lie Matick I mean,
he's first ballot hall of fame quarterback and first ballot hall of fame.
Like,
I don't know.
How much more does that guy have to win before you,
you,
you like,
you could look at him wearing a helmet.
There's just something about it.
He looks like he's sitting between two fucking muscular people on a plane.
He like,
he got the middle seat,
the shoulders or motion,
his face together.
MMM.
I got a lot of balls considering the way I fucking look.
Huh.
Anyways.
Anyways,
I fucking ran out of batteries.
You wouldn't know because I just said anyways,
cause it magically ended with me saying anyways.
But I did,
I just did.
I just said like another 10 minutes of the podcast after.
Okay.
I was talking about Eli sitting between two muscular guys on a fucking plane and
uh,
I dunno,
you know,
I got to read these.
God Damn,
I gotta read the fucking advertising against.
So no,
this all right.
This is my second.
I've already read these one time,
so I should breeze through these.
I should breeze through these.
Um,
anyways,
my bookie.
Yeah,
that cricket is a loud ass.
Fucking cricket was,
maybe that's the amount of people leaving the podcast at this point.
I have no idea.
My bookie,
uh,
you know,
ever since I started this podcast,
people have been asking for my advice,
asked me,
you know,
ask me what team do I bet on?
The truth is,
I don't know who's got a win.
That's the truce piece of advertising that's ever been written for me to say.
I don't know who's going to win,
but if you think,
you know,
you got to check out my bookie,
okay.
Remember who you're betting on is just as important as who you bet in with.
That's why this fucking crickets going to drive me crazy.
That's why I always tell people to bet with my bookie.
Do I,
I guess I do.
According to the copy.
Trust me guys,
they are your best bet this season.
Uh,
they'd been in business for years.
Um,
have great reviews online and their mobile site is easy to use.
Listen to that cricket start and get his fucking bed in for the Thursday
afternoon,
Thursday night gig.
My bookie,
you when they pay.
So like these other plugin bookies were you when you pay,
listen,
if you,
when they pay,
if you lose,
you have to pay.
Don't ever forget that.
All right?
They have in game live betting the most rewarding perks in the business.
If you fantasy guys out there,
Huh?
Stop Robin one out to your seventh grade math teacher.
You can even bet on the over under on how many fantasy points of player will
score each game.
It's the game within the game.
It's like it's like the middle earth of football.
My is slammed with new betters and wants to give everyone the best service
possible.
If you're willing to deposit after 7:00 PM eastern time,
they'll give you an additional $25 free to play on deposits of our hundred
dollars.
Do you think that's why they're doing it?
Are they adjusting the line?
I have no idea.
That's fucking amazing that they're doing it.
So jump on it because who gives a shit,
right?
Either way.
You know it's a fucking shot.
One bed away from you.
Join now and my book,
He will match your deposit dollar for dollar.
Use Promo code bird activate the offer.
Visit my bookie online today.
That's my bookie.
And don't forget to use the Promo Code Bur when creating your account to claim
up to $1,000 in free play and now and now,
if you're willing to hold out until after 7:00 PM,
you can get an extra 25 bucks for free by using the Promo curb code.
Sorry,
bird 25.
MMM,
it's up to you guys.
Uh,
but I'd wait until after dinner and take the extra money you play.
You win,
you get paid and listen to that after the part.
I can't see that one.
But you listen after Thursday podcast,
you can hear when they call in the sports gambling podcasts was showing green
and rang Kweyma
John Ellis Shave Club of watching a sports show right now,
both guys who were wearing shoes and one guy's wearing high top sneakers just to
let you know that he's into sports,
even though he has own a suit at heart.
He's a guy who goes the watches the sports.
He must be the crazy guy in the shop.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
No matter what you do in the bathroom to get ready,
dollar shave club has everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best.
They have amazing shower stuff,
hairstyling products,
toothbrushes and toothpaste.
That of course raises and shaved supplies.
Just to let you know,
I finally got those one wipe Charlies problem.
Uh,
they do work amazing,
but the late,
you know,
uh,
there is some sort of like a tingling afterwards.
All right.
Almost like they put a wintergreen lifesaver in there or something.
I have no idea.
But just to let you know that that's,
you know,
yeah.
Just in case you get,
you think you got to fucking tapeworm or something working its way out of here.
Uh,
you might shave your whole body to get ready for a bike race.
Dollar Shave Club's executive razor and shave butter can help you.
Uh,
you might do your hair to get ready for your soccer match.
Bogies by dollar shave club and get can help you style your hair.
Right.
I've already read this.
The thing is,
no matter what you do to get ready of dollar shave club has everything you need.
This is my second.
I've already read this.
I already had a rehearsal.
I'm still fucking it up right now.
You can get ready with an amazing deal on any one of their status sets,
like daily essentials.
Essential started said,
but you can't go wrong with that.
Iom.
Head over to dollar shave club.com/for pick your own dollar shave club status
set for just $5 after you started set product ship at regular price and make
sure you check out their new video.
Two,
that's dollar shave club.com/bird dollar shave club.com such [inaudible].
I'm hoping when this recorder cut out,
it didn't cut out the shit I was talking about about f one in Moto GP.
Um,
so in case it did,
I might fucking directv.
Has it been working well and I missed the last couple of races,
but I'm back in there.
All right,
back in,
back in at that.
All right.
stamps.com everybody,
uh,
the US Postal Service is a very important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access all the amazing services of the post
office.
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24,
seven print postage for any class mail Friday class baile right from your own
computer.
A buy and print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer,
they'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the best place of a class of mail based on
your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter.
And there are no long term commitments.
I use stamps.com to send out my posters.
50 for my tour called 50 simply called fifth 50.
Simply red is now 50.
Uh,
include your personal recommendation.
Well,
I'm a more on if I can figure out how to do it.
So can you right now?
You too can enjoy the stamps.com service without a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
You know what I love about having stamps.com and my fucking house is I got a kid
now.
All right.
By the time I put the kid to bed,
the post office is closed so I can get everything all fucking ready to go.
I get a jump on the day.
If I do that and I get all the dishes done.
Aw,
I wake up in the greatest mood ever.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstamps.com enter.
All righty then.
Um,
I know I keep teasing you guys with this fucking eastern European tour,
but it is coming back together.
It is slowly but surely it's coming together.
Well,
we had to,
you know,
they had me gone for like fucking 17 days and you know,
I can't do that.
I got a kid.
All right,
I'm going to come home.
The kids aren't going to recognize me,
so I'm going to break it up into two tours.
That is the game plan.
MMM.
Oh,
that's cool.
Or Bill's quarterback retired and fucking half time.
But he'll be wanting to do that.
He made one last stop and he said,
I'm out of here.
It's kind of a cool way to do it.
Um,
anyways,
and we'll definitely be getting out there and I know people from Australia but
asking me,
I'm going to try and make something like next year.
I think I might do like a couple of those little runs there,
let him overseas.
Um,
and maybe take another special,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
We'll see.
Alright.
Allman Fam.
Hey Bill,
thanks for the semi shout out to the blue moon echelon tree nut,
the Allmond on your podcast last Monday.
Oh yeah,
three.
I said it was the moon blue moon of the nuts.
Uh,
on
September 10th,
2018 I was walking through my RL almond orchard listening your podcast when you
talked about seeing your first almond tree.
I live in the region of Thunder Valley.
Wasn't able to make it to the show,
but I hope that's not your last time in the Sacramento area.
I fucking loved that Gig.
That gig was so much fun.
That crowd was awesome.
I'll tell you right now,
there's a lot of concern out there,
but all been farmers.
There are right?
You guys are all right with me.
It is.
Anyways,
he says,
I am a tree nut farmer in California is a prominent producer of mini tree nut
crops including almonds,
walnuts,
pecans and pistachios.
Yes.
Yes and yes.
MMM.
Stay these pistachios that they like the Doritos of nuts.
What you want you to start eating meat.
You're fucked.
You got to get air lifted out of there.
You're going to get the rest of them.
Uh,
almond bloom in February and it's a beautiful time of the year.
If you and your family are ever up here,
please stop by for a visit.
Well I gotta be honest with you.
I respect farmers even though my big funny when I'm been farming country,
cause that's what I do.
What am I going to say?
I respect farmers and get that douchey applause break.
You know,
like I'm some politician running for office.
Okay.
And now next I'm going to say exactly what you want to hear.
You know,
a lot.
I like my opponent.
So itself said that you guys are a,
you guys are lazy,
but I'll tell you I am ever is going to be like
[inaudible] I bet here for the last three days when I helped that guy Bevers
Risley and hey,
by your,
where are going to,
are you
cable?
And every will lose their fucking mind with their dumb fuck an American flag hat
.
MMM.
Isn't it weird how dumb people are that actually show up to shit like that are,
you know,
I always noticed that.
Yeah.
Like when I was doing on the opiate Anthony Show,
they had a bunch of people out,
listeners that we're fucking smart.
But whenever you did a remote,
the fucking animals that showed up and it's the same fucking thing.
Would politicians go on the road?
You know,
they're running for those primaries and stuff and you just look at the people in
the fucking crowd,
you know?
Yeah.
Inherently they gotta [inaudible] they don't have a fucking job.
Right.
What are they doing there?
Okay,
well maybe they're down there cause he needed a job and they believe in that kid
candidate.
Well.
Yeah,
I full just full fucking vote for him.
Then the big time go go fucking
hit the bricks and try to find a job.
Oh,
Bill,
what are you going to stop over simplifying things and actually try to read up
on stuff?
I don't know.
Okay.
Did a lot of the charm of the podcast be gone?
If I did that,
you know,
is it me or is the sound of that cricket?
Fucking definitely.
It's like it's in here.
It's like,
it's slowly sneaking up on me to fucking,
you know,
is that the latest?
Uh Oh my God.
Look at that.
Two young kids playing guitar.
Holy Shit.
Did they play the national anthem?
Oh thank God.
There's hope.
They keep playing a Gibson Les Paul,
you spoiled God set up the phone
that's going to save the fuck
the rich kid.
You know,
rich kid goes to the concerts like,
I like that drum kit and the parents go out and buy the exact one.
You know?
Does that kit ever make it
okay?
Did he ever beat one rich kid that made it?
Can you say Donald Trump made it?
You have to,
even though he was rich,
he turned the millions into billions and then he,
but he,
he's,
he's fucking president of the United States.
No matter how much you hate the guy,
you got a video,
he made it.
He is a fucking American success story.
Like if you were at the track.
Okay.
And you,
I mean,
if he was the odds,
what would the fucking odds,
I can't imagine.
I still cannot fucking believe that guy pulled that shit off.
Yup.
It's like watching Tom Brady throw for 500 yards at a super bowl is still
somehow losing.
Like how does that happen?
All right.
So I've been under the weather the last couple of days,
but I stayed on the,
uh,
I stayed on the Diet and,
oh,
do I have a fun,
I have a story,
but I can't tell it right now.
I have to wait.
I get a weight of like months from now or I feel like I can tell the fucking
story.
But,
uh,
anyways,
I watched that boxing match,
you know,
triple c guy where I don't know any,
I,
I've been away from boxing for so fucking long.
I just got so fed up with how fucking corrupt it was.
Uh,
just getting burned.
Yeah.
On paper views.
You know what I mean?
Like I really feel like Floyd Mayweather,
the people that I'm still won't give it up.
How great that guy is.
Like,
it's just a fucking shame that that guy didn't fight Pacquiao in the two
thousands,
you know?
And then we all got taken for a fucking ride when he did and now I'm seeing that
he's going to fight him again and
lead.
Personally,
I think that guy is undeniably,
hm.
What are the greatest of all times?
Without a fucking doubt it,
but you can't argue that,
but I really think these,
these cash grabs
I,
that just doesn't help be,
it maybe doesn't give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
Fight and column and Gregor and I,
are you going to fight like fucking packy hour again?
I,
but anyways,
but I,
I watched that fight,
couple of fucking warriors.
I came in and went to a party and I saw like the last three rounds of it,
I was like,
fuck,
I wish I saw this whole thing.
But I remember version was giving me shit because they like,
you know,
dude,
I can't get into fucking ever bay.
I really love boxing.
Boxing like so much better and blah blah blah blah blah blah.
And I have to be a great fucking boxing match
as far as like combat sports.
I still,
you know what,
I have to agree.
I don't think you can touch it
and we don't want to like about it because I love MMA.
Fucking love the shit.
But like,
like when you watch those like this stand up game in MMA,
it,
you can't touch a box.
Now I know all you MMA guys going to flip out.
Yeah,
you put a box on his back and he's done.
I understand that.
But it's the fact that all they do is throw punches.
Like how fucking good they are in boxing.
It's incredible.
Um,
like the,
the level of skill and those guys were just in the center of the ring for the
last three rounds.
I would watch it essentially just bang and just beat the shit out of each other.
And I know a lot of people didn't like the,
uh,
the decision and I always go to how corrupt fucking boxing is.
And the thing that I like about the UFC is despite the fact that it's sort of
like apple where it's like this borderline monopoly and uh,
but they can at least,
you know,
the best guys fight the best guys for the most part.
I know it's not a perfect system,
but there's not like,
you know,
three different leagues in somebody who has to try and unify the title and all
that Shit.
All right.
For some fucking reason I went to,
uh,
I just hit stop against that.
I got three fucking ones.
I got to edit together.
Such an idiot.
Um,
anyways,
yeah.
So is that,
you don't have fucking,
I'll tell this story.
I'm just going to name any names.
I was at this party,
um,
one of these like really cool la parties that you hope you get invited to.
And I got invited to it and they had Cuban cigars there,
which was fucking incredible.
As a beautiful house,
beautiful house.
And I went into the,
uh,
I went into this room with,
you know,
the TV room they had that they had the boxing match on and I look over and a
fucking,
one of the greatest boxers for when I was growing up was there.
And it was fucking hilarious because it was him.
And then just a bunch of regular people like me who didn't fight,
you know,
ever or whatever,
you know.
So he's sitting there,
so it was like,
you did want to comment,
you didn't want to say anything,
but you wanted to say something cause you wanted to show that you knew
something.
It was fucking hilarious.
People would try to be,
everybody was like,
you know,
wanting to say something,
but then kind of like not wanting,
it was fucking hilarious.
So I didn't say anything.
I'm like,
I hate to say it.
Fucking shit is no fucking way.
I'm going to be like,
Ugh,
throw left.
Fuck his hands are too low.
Why?
Why set it up with the jab?
Like I'm going to fucking say that with this champions sitting there.
Right.
So,
uh,
my interaction was this tea.
At the end of the fight there was the decision
then this one of the greatest fighters of all time was just,
ah,
man,
come on.
And I just said no.
And he went no.
And that was my interaction.
I left the room.
I was like,
all right,
I got my interaction,
but there was no fucking way.
Okay.
There was no fucking way.
I,
I just,
you know,
I just watched the fight and was praying to God.
He would make some comments,
which he did a couple of times and it was just like,
oh my God,
this is,
unbelief is on fucking believable.
Uh,
don't ever let anybody have a shit on fucking la.
I'm telling you,
you get out here,
bust your fucking ass.
And then I'm telling you the fucking people that you meet,
even just for two seconds and you have a one word again,
strange.
It's like you gotta be kidding me.
I remember a long time ago when I was,
I was just struggling in this business and I was on the fucking,
uh,
the Fox lot.
Okay.
And uh,
yeah,
I just bombed some audition and I was just like,
what am I doing out here?
I shouldn't be out here.
I should be in New York trying to get better as a comedian.
It's just,
I just knew this wasn't my road.
So I was walking out and it was all fucking depressed.
And as I was walking across the lot fucking Henry Winkler,
this is like 20 years ago,
right around the time he was doing the water boy just came walking by.
Yeah.
I was like,
that was fucking know it was Henry fucking Winkler.
I just got that.
That's how fucking cool is that I am somehow
was in his fucking life for like five seconds,
whatever I'm doing leads to meeting that guy
and then like fucking,
I dunno,
20 years after that
bill haters show Barry comes out and next thing you know they want me to
interview the cast that I was fucking sitting there and talking to
Henry Winkler Erie.
It's an incredible place that probably won't be here.
Look,
there's global warming.
I don't know.
Who knows?
I'd say get out here now.
Why you still can't,
you know,
go down to Miami,
check these places.
These places are going to be,
you're going to be like somebody like,
you know when you're all the talking about how you,
you yeah.
Pompei pay.
I was there man.
Fuck yeah,
I was there before the waters came up.
I was fucking there.
I did so blow.
I got my dick sucked and I had some fucking crab legs.
So if you can say it like an old man
to watch oh,
chic,
right,
whatever the fuck you'd say.
Like doing blow at that point would probably be like,
you know,
bringing up,
doing the one,
two c,
whatever the fuck that was.
Yeah.
What was that like?
Some sort of minor dance.
Okay.
You know like what qualified as a fucking day.
Like it is an amazing
just how human beings progress creatively.
They like the Charleston,
Charleston child's Dan Badda boom,
boom.
Right.
And now like what?
What,
how well some of these kids can fucking dance just in clubs.
It's like back in the day like Fred Astaire would be asking for a goddamn
lesson.
It's like Odell Beckham
ever since he made that falling backwards while getting interfered with one
handed,
like as far back as you can reach behind your head catch.
Nobody's ever made a catch like that now.
Like I don't know what they're doing that doing this thing with their strength
and their,
their fingers or they are just practicing it.
Like the guy in the Jag was did it.
Like I watched that.
The only thing that was as well,
I can't say it was as good as Odell cause it.
That was the first guy to do it.
Andy and the big thing was he was getting interfered with while falling down
backwards.
Um,
boost guy just,
he just reached out like those like Spiderman,
just snag the thing,
then move it around so the defender could knock it out of his hand and like
that's like a,
that's sort of the joy I got him in.
It's like the Jordan effect.
Like that shit that you know Colby was doing like by like they all saw Jordan to
it and then they added it to their game cause he's showed the,
hey you,
this is possible.
What are you talking about?
I don't know.
I'm trying to say some deposited before I try and try and see how great la is
and then the back of my head I'm like,
you know it's going to be fucking,
yeah,
I don't know when it's going to be.
All I know is I got a weird feeling that it's going to be all green and it's
going to be raining like the fucking rain forest,
you know,
they said that it's going to be like you get,
it's going to be like weird weather.
I think it's going to be just everything,
like whatever.
It used to be like the east coast is going to get all fucking hot.
It's going to be a Goddamn desert.
And then out here is going to be like lush.
I don't think it's going to eaten lunch land.
That's just wishful fucking thinking.
I Dunno who the fuck knows who the fuck are.
They've always spent saying that we're going to fall into the goddamn emotion
and all that shit.
Um,
do you guys watch any of that college football?
What a fucking weekend.
You know what,
when I went out to go to that party,
uh,
I could feel that Ohio state Tcu game was gay,
was I knew I was leaving early and I had,
so I think I missed the game of the year so far.
Um,
and by the way,
uh,
Oh,
before I move on to the next game,
Tcu,
by the way,
how quickly are they on their way to probation?
You know,
I don't get these guys.
These guys came out of nowhere.
They were great and then they fell off,
which you see now all of a sudden they're great again
and a Texas and it's three letters,
Tcu,
Smu,
I'm telling you there's something there.
I'm just fucking with you.
Tcu is what I fucking love.
Watching that team man exciting as hell and uh,
almost had a great comeback against the Ohio state.
Um,
and there are two went.
Oh well their coaches suspended.
He's allowed to coach during the fucking wake,
but on,
on Saturdays,
he is not allowed to couch.
Um,
tell me,
you don't have some sort of hedge sent wire thing going on or some shit.
Um,
Urban Meyer,
uh,
anyways,
plowing your head here.
That kid from north Texas who did the,
uh,
the fake fair catch.
Yeah.
Uh,
the next time he calls for a fair catch,
he better be waving a goddamn white flag.
There's that dude is going to get stuck for the rest of the fucking year cause
he,
he humiliated whoever the fuck he did that too.
When people see shit like that,
y'all ain't fucking do that to me.
Then they give you the all right there Fred.
So keep your head on a swivel.
Their sunny.
Um,
I still don't understand how the fuck he pulled that off.
You know?
Yeah.
Big Time.
Confidence,
big time.
Fucking confidence.
Um,
did I read from the almond farmer yet that I did.
I miss that one.
Did that one get cut off at all?
The fucking confusion here.
This almond farmer wrote me,
he said he was actually listening to the podcast while I was talking about
almond farm.
Then he invited me,
you know,
to stop by,
which is always creepy,
you know what I mean?
Those farmhouses like I love far miles and now I fucking shit.
Right.
But like they're all scary looking farm.
Ours is,
are there,
there's scary during the day
because you never see anybody and he just always feel like they have all these,
this,
this old fucking,
they have like sickles and shit.
It's just,
you know,
they can feed to their pigs.
I Dunno,
they were shady group man.
Those farmers,
they're out there by themselves.
You can't tell me you don't slowly go insane when you're fucking a fee when
you're a farmer.
You know what I mean?
Then when you fucking a farmer,
all right ladies,
you keep doing that shit.
All right.
You don't have to be lonely.
Play in with his fucking almond scented balls.
All right.
Living off of smoothies.
Oh Lsu by the way,
Lsu is fucking two and now,
um,
I watched the whole game.
I watched the whole game and I watched so many sports,
so much sports this weekend.
I,
I can't even remember who the fuck they played.
Auburn.
Jesus Christ in Auburn,
right
war.
Fucking Eagle,
right.
They went down there and they went down there and they fucking,
I don't a lot of those Auburn people,
they're upset.
They'll lie on,
hey wait one on am fucking pass in or fairer girl scouts book and calls.
Um,
I am a big proponent of quarterbacks and how much they get fucked over.
But I,
both of those were in interference.
If you were at the game,
that one over the middle looks like bullshit cause they didn't show you the full
replay where the guy just held him for like,
you know,
10 yards.
Totally slowed them the fuck down.
And then the other one,
the guy was grabbing his fucking arm,
you know,
it was borderline.
Sometimes you get away with it,
but he got caught.
But he was doing it.
I can tell you this,
uh,
we're fucking two went.
Oh,
and what's his face there?
Their coach.
The hell's his goddamn name.
I'd just keep spacing on his fucking name.
I'll get it.
Uh,
that's,
he's,
he's the best thing in the sec,
if not in the fucking
college football right now.
Oh,
I tweeted that.
He's,
he,
he's
sounds like a fucking a Cajun hulk.
Hogan
in origin.
Ron
[inaudible] Ron now.
Okay.
Alternative rundown.
We went out,
I'll tell you Trump to what brought up,
uh,
he sounds like a fucking wrestler and he's got and believing in themselves and
they got a quarterback that's playing out right now.
Look,
we all know the Alabama Crimson tide is a fucking professional football team.
All right.
I don't know what the Fuck Nick Saban is doing.
How he gets all those good guys.
Howie's always fun.
I don't know what,
but that guy is the fucking guy.
Nick Saban.
I love rooting against them,
but I love that guy.
I love Nick Saban.
You know,
I love what he's done with the Alabama or whatever,
but you know,
when I needed to pick a college team I wasn't going to fucking jump on the
bandwagon.
You know,
I like rooting against the fucking people.
You know what I mean?
Well Do.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Maybe you don't.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead,
living off smoothies.
Hey Billy,
fish paste.
Um,
last week you mentioned you'd love to just live off smoothies if you could.
Well,
it turns out you can,
there's an entire niche food market called meal replacements or complete foods
that contain all the carbs,
fats,
proteins,
fibers,
micronutrients and everything else.
The body needs to function properly,
all in one serving.
Yeah,
I know,
but I get nervous cause when I,
I,
I just feel like it's,
it's science and then they always put all these fucking chemicals and shit in
there.
Uh,
some come in powder form.
So all you do is mix it with water.
Others come ready to drink in the bottle.
The difference between them and something shitty like ensure is that they take
human biology and complete nutritional needs into account and make sure you get
the full recommended daily intake for all vitamins,
minerals,
macros.
Eh,
also most of them are made from whole food ingredients.
Um,
this is probably what the future's going to be like when we fucking destroy the
whole planet.
And the only people left are living in this giant air conditioned fucking
greenhouse.
Uh,
and they just in there with,
I don't know what chemicals,
but eventually you need plants so that they,
they just,
they can't their own ecosystem.
They're like,
we're going to heal the earth from inside here and then it's going to work on
the way out.
There's another side.
I always pitch these Psi Phi movies,
you know,
and then years later they ended up making them like that fucking population
jumped that I did that.
You take a test,
they literally made that fucking movie.
Where's another one for you yet even can actually go ahead and make it,
cause I'm not going to fucking do it.
Did you just give consent?
Um,
here's one for you,
right?
The whole fucking world looks like a Goddamn desert is all waterworld desert and
all that shit and it's just this one fucking greed house,
giant fucking greenhouse,
the size of Dallas Cowboys Stadium.
And in there they actually have plants,
they've got some chickens and shits like a fucking arc that doesn't go anywhere.
Right?
And in there is the perfect fucking ecosystem.
All right.
And then they're going to gradually,
like their thing is,
is if they have to weight out all the waste and hope that the planet comes back
and then they gradually,
every year they try to expand a little bit more of this stadium to fucking
include more.
The more of this declivity claim more than fucking scorched earth.
Right.
I'm already off the rails.
I don't have this fucker works.
But somehow there's a fucking guy in there and he wants to take control and it's
all about the fucking air conditioner.
Right.
That was a bad one.
But some one of you nerds can figure it out.
Right.
All right.
Anyways,
the one that first came online a few years ago was called,
this is back to the living off smooth smoothies.
Soylent.
They make powder in premixed drinks.
Very tasty.
But there's doesn't of other companies that make similar products.
You know,
one of the guys I fly with a,
you know,
these digestive system,
whatever,
that's all he does.
And he,
we flew back from,
uh,
this place one time when I was hungry,
he was drink this man,
you'll be full.
And I drank it and it felt good,
but it was,
it was too weird,
man.
I need to,
I would need to read up on it.
Um,
but I know I'm not going to,
so I'm going to stick with what I've been doing,
but uh,
but I,
I would think that you'd be in great shape.
Right.
You know,
it's nice and easy to digest.
I don't know.
It depends on what's in it though,
right?
Anyways,
it doesn't have other companies that make similar products like Hule.
He will that we happy
Hule Huel,
Jimmy joy,
bio lint and super body fuel all with their very own special take on how to
fulfill requirements.
It's been working for me for years and I even lived off soylent for a month
straight a couple of years ago with no issues along with hundreds of other
people.
But you obviously don't have to do that.
You can just use it for breakfast or ever you want.
Thanks for all your left and go fuck yourself.
Well let me,
did you lose a bunch of weight and shit?
Like why don't fat people just fucking do this
or look into it?
You know,
cause I figured that once they push through and get off the sugar salt,
they can start turning it around.
Um,
and one of the hardest things to do about eating healthy is,
is now you got to sit there and prepare this shit while you're super hungry and
your body's going to fuck this order.
A pizza man order a fucking pizza.
But if they just all these containers ready to go,
you just shake it up and you drink it.
Um,
that could actually help some people.
Uh,
but I,
I would definitely,
if you're going to do that,
if you listen to you're thinking of doing,
I would definitely do some research as far as like what is in them.
Alright.
Boycott dear Billy boy caught.
How do you feel about boycotting?
Have you ever boycotted anything?
Uh,
yes,
I have.
Uh,
is there any reason you would boycott a show podcasts your company because you
didn't agree with their behavior?
Um,
no.
Are Not their opinions.
I would,
I would like,
uh,
if something sucked.
So I don't know.
I guess that's sent a boycott then.
All right.
Anyways,
he goes,
I feel like you have a thick skin,
so you probably have only,
you probably only have reason to boycott a group that was censoring you are your
comedy.
Um,
yeah,
like when I boy caught something,
when I boycott a company because of their behavior,
well I hate bankers,
but I still fucking use him.
So that goes that.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I respect people that that's what they want to fucking do.
I would put it that way,
but like,
yeah,
I don't know that I would,
uh,
thank,
you know,
I get why people do that shit.
You just have to do a lot to fucking lose me,
I think.
You know what I mean?
Like I hung in there with Trump and you know,
cause I root for the president whether I like them or not,
but like once his wife wore that,
yeah,
I don't know.
I really care.
Do you jacket to that fucking,
you know,
when she's going down to see kids that were taken away from their parents,
I mean,
whether they're right or wrong about their way they're handling immigration or
how they want to enforce it,
that,
you know,
that goes out the window when there's some kid crying missing his parents and
he's,
he or she's scared,
you know,
and you're going to wear something like that.
That's when they lost me and I was just like,
all right,
I'm by subtle and trash from in my act.
You know,
Kendall's is fucking plenty of people doing that.
Um,
so I may be honest,
you get this at this point in history,
I think it's really important rather than to walk away or something like that.
It's more important to try to get something going to talk or something cause
this screaming and yelling shit.
Jesus.
And this comes from somebody who will fucking screaming cunt.
Um,
you know,
it's just,
it doesn't,
uh,
it doesn't fucking
doesn't make any sense.
I understand why people do what they get.
They get emotional.
Jesus Christ.
God knows I've got fucking emotional today.
This guy was supposed to move some fucking furniture.
I in my house,
it's one of the fucking workers.
Like I,
you know,
I did all this work on the house and like I loved the house as much as I bitch
about it.
And you know,
I brought it back to life where a lot of people did some home depot bullshit to
it and I tried to restore it,
you know,
update it in the walls but like outside and tried to make it look like,
um,
you know,
the time when it was created,
you know.
So I went and I got these vintage door handles and somebody swiped one of them
and I swear to fuck I got it back though.
I got it.
I raised fucking holy hell,
it's one of the few times my wife didn't give me shit for losing my mind.
I,
I fucking lost my fucking mind.
What is that about when somebody steals from you?
You know,
it's just that they,
it's like,
I think who do fuck does he think I'm that fucking stupid?
I wasn't going to notice.
Do you think on the kind of person that's,
that's not going to fucking pursue this?
I,
Ooh,
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
well there's a reason I don't fucking own a firearm.
You know,
you can't,
you know,
so that's one of those things that they should do is when you go down and get a
fucking a gun license,
they should like spy on you for a week and just figure out what irritates you
and then they just come in and do it.
Just have somebody do it to you in the parking lot and just see how much you
lose your shit and just see if he should have a fucking gun or not.
Um,
I would never shoot anybody,
but I think I would definitely brandish a weapon.
I'm fucking wave in somebody's face,
buddy.
I am going to shoot you in the face,
you know,
put your fucking hands in that dashboard.
One of those underrated performances in any terantin of movie.
The guy who played that fucking cup,
um,
in the bathroom scene.
All right,
buying a Lamborghini.
Hey Billy,
the financial advisor
just might be my favorite fucking question ever.
Are you going to buy a Lamborghini?
You ever just live vicariously through somebody?
Uh,
more of a Ferrari guy?
But God bless you.
You know,
I'm not a Lamborghini.
Guys are more flashy.
A,
hey,
Billy,
the financial adviser.
I,
I'd appreciate your take.
My childhood dream has been to own a Lamborghini then God damn it.
Get yourself not because of the,
Oh is he says I'd attract,
but because I have a huge interest in cars and they've always been a motivation
for me.
A problem is I'm not a hundred percent sure if I should.
I should.
I left a word out,
drop 250 grand on a car.
I know the old saying,
if you have to ask,
uh,
you can't afford it.
Uh,
it has truth to it,
but I'd like to get advice from people on a big decision.
We'll dude,
I'm not the guy.
I'm currently 27.
He says,
did my master's and work a commission based job,
a real realtor,
and luckily had a few good years in the past.
Um,
from the money I saved,
I managed to buy three investment properties.
Oh Dude,
you're,
yes.
Okay.
This is all great stuff.
I know technically they belong to the bank,
but I've been able to build equity that way.
The shitty thing is because I've been buying these,
I ended up not buying a place for myself and my parents had been nice enough to
let me stay home with them.
I know that this is kind of fucked up,
but I'm from South Africa and it's frowned upon to move out before getting
married.
Well,
dude,
you save a ton of money.
So I guess I kind of took advantage of that.
No,
he didn't,
that,
that was their rule and you'd just,
you're playing within the rules anyways.
Also,
you tell them a patriots fan.
There's nothing wrong with that then and say he can't do it.
Also,
I don't have a girlfriend and actually don't get laid at all.
So I'm not doing it to impress girl.
I could give a fuck about you or just a fucking asexual moneymaking machine
here,
sir.
My question is,
should I buy my own place first then save up for a lambo or fulfill my childhood
dream?
Now.
Uh,
the reason I don't want to necessarily buy a places because then I'll have a lot
of pressure to find a wife and I know no woman will ever let me spend 250 grand
on a car and let's say spent 250 grand on her and because it may delay my dream
and other five or so years and I want to enjoy it while I'm still relatively
young.
All right.
Wow.
This guy's really planning out his life.
I liked this also,
if it matters,
I have about half of the amount I need saved up so far and will either save up
for another six months to a year and yes,
I've researched maintenance costs and if factored those into its guy's done his
homework,
any help would be appreciated.
Thanks for the free podcast and any advice from near would be helpful to you
guys are great together and I wish I had friends in real life like you guys.
That's really nice.
Now that I'm done sucking your tick,
thanks and go fuck yourself.
That's hilarious.
Um,
all right.
Well,
I think you know more about money than I do.
Um,
here's the pros to buy a Lamborghini.
they do retain their value.
Okay?
If you don't wrap it around a fucking tree or modify it or do a bunch of,
you know,
put a bunch of miles on it.
The weird thing about a Lamborghini is that,
you know,
these fucking guys get them and then they have them for 20 years and they sell
them and they always have like 800 original miles.
And it's like,
why the fuck did you even have it?
Uh,
secondly,
um,
I don't know if it helps you.
It's not a good look.
If your real estate agent is 27 and pulls up in a fucking Lamborghini,
that would make me feel like this guy's taken way too much commission.
He's fucking me.
So I,
if you're going to get it,
I would not drive it to work.
Um,
and as far as your worry about women,
uh,
here's,
here's the secret with women is you gotta be up front with them.
Okay?
You have to tell them from fucking day one that this is what you're doing and
then you have to follow through and do it.
And don't let them do that shit where they go.
Well,
that was there for,
I was predicted.
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
All right.
Um,
I,
I would lean,
I would,
uh,
listen,
I think there's,
there's a massive like bubble being built in and I don't know shit.
So people don't listen to me.
Okay.
I know I'm a bald guy and I know I screen,
but I'm not that guy on TV who yells about the stocks.
I'm just a fucking stupid comedian.
Okay.
And I go with my gut and my gut is,
was a travel round the country up.
Fucking look at paypal.
All right?
And what's been freaking me out is the shit that I'm talking about where,
uh,
it's like a fucking Thursday afternoon.
I'm on the road and I go to a breakfast place and it is fucking packed.
I'm standing in line like it's Sunday after church and I'm just looking around
going donated.
These fucking people have a fucking job.
And I'm looking at them all and they all have smart phones and they have fucking
iPads and they got fucking their custom fucking sneakers that they ordered in.
Everybody is living this fucking lifestyle and part of this lifestyle is in
building all these fucking luxury high rise apartments.
I mean this is my fifth time around the block with this shit.
All right.
Started with the fucking yuppies was the first time I saw it.
The fucking Dotcom Shit.
Uh,
the,
the housing bubble lamb,
everybody's getting a house,
you know,
from fucking 10 years ago and now this shit.
So maybe it's my fourth time through this,
but this is,
this is what happens.
So,
um,
I think keep doing what you're doing with the money and either stay at home.
I wouldn't buy,
I wouldn't buy the loan.
No,
I want,
I don't want to talk to you.
It's a fucking dream or so I,
I'm,
there's no way I'm going to talk a guy and up his dream or a woman or a
hermaphrodite or somebody transitioning.
Did I cover everybody?
Am I still in show business?
Um,
I,
uh,
and then as far as the pressure,
you're going to get to get married a fuck that.
Okay.
At some point you gotta be like,
listen,
I'm not doing that.
Okay.
I'm going to get married when I find the right person.
And if you don't,
I'm talking about just watched coming to America.
Okay.
I think you're going to find a lot of themes that you can relate to.
Um,
that's your,
my coming to America is kill the Irishmen.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
yeah,
I think,
you know,
here's the thing is another way to have a Lamborghini.
You could have a Lamborghini for like a year and then turn around and sell it.
You know,
my only thing is I think I,
I would kind of wait until the fucking Lamborghini is a great thing to buy
during a recession.
Okay.
Unless you're talking about buying a new one,
then,
you know.
But,
um,
okay.
I mean,
you're,
you're always going to be able to sell a fucking Lamborghini and I've never seen
,
um,
well,
you know,
let's fucking look them up,
by the way.
I fucking love this team.
I love anybody with a fucking dream.
And this guy,
like he wants a fucking Lamborghini and God damn it,
he's gonna figure out how to do it.
I love this Lamborghini,
uh,
used for sale.
All right,
let's see what we got here.
Let's see what we got to use.
Lamborghini first sale.
Um,
$35,900.
17,900 909.
See,
this is why you don't listen to me.
Is that the poster?
Is that the actual fucking car?
Are you serious?
Oh,
that's a kit.
You fucking cunt.
It's not a real one.
Use Lamborghini.
Wait,
those are all fucking kid cars.
You fucking assholes.
All right,
hang on a second.
All right.
This is more like use 2017 Lamborghini,
uh,
event the dog as coupon on I say
$399,711 a used 2017.
Here's another thing,
dude,
you can fucking get one.
Buy used one.
Okay.
There's a used 2007 Lamborghini's still going to turn heads for $99,995.
2017 lambo.
You can get for two Oh oh nine five 82 door coupe
there.
Then you can get a 2018 Volvo s 90 for $375.
I don't know who the fuck is looking at this as well.
Maybe I'd like a Volvo.
Um,
use 2008 Lamborghini Murcia Lego revention coop.
For some reason they want 1,000,008 and 18.
What?
No fucking way.
There's another oil is another.
All those doe.
All those are the kitty ones.
These are the big boys here.
Use 2017 Lamborghini,
Evan Taito,
LP seven 54 soup.
Super Villains,
roadster.
I know it says 659,009,
uh,
$900.
These are a year old and these are all like a half a million bucks.
Um,
yeah,
dude,
you don't want to spend all this fucking money.
Maybe you don't worry.
Do I would I would buy a used one though.
I would definitely buy a fucking use one.
Holy Shit.
You know what kills me about these things?
If you go to the,
wouldn't go to the supermarket and drive over a fucking speed bump,
please tell me those circuits you get this thing.
Please take it to the track.
Could you please,
could you please take it to the track,
the amount of Lamborghinis and never go to the fucking track.
You know that if I got one of those fucking things,
I'd have it on a flatbed truck.
I'd take it to the track and I would meet an instructor there and be like,
teach me to drive this thing as fast as my skill set will allow me,
um,
without fucking destroying it.
All right,
let's close on this dilemma,
but good luck to you sir.
Uh,
you got a lot of great options.
Okay.
Uh,
tell the woman what you're going to do and stick with it.
What she gonna do.
Be Up,
you know?
Um,
and then secondly,
you got to let go that shit with your parents.
If you're going,
don't,
don't not buy a house because of some fucking,
you know,
pot of gold at the end of the rainbow.
Sorry,
I always have to go with the fucking some sort of where I'm from kind of thing
here.
A dilemma.
Everybody,
Dear Belle,
if your life depended on it,
would you in Chris Berman's voice what you live in medieval times as a king or
make 65 grand a year in the present time.
Oh fuck that.
Oh my God.
As a king you be able to fuck any chick you wanted.
Eat well,
live well do king shit.
But you'd have to worry about being overthrown or invaded.
Yeah.
Or getting some fucking disease and yeah.
And smallpox.
Everyone asked this question to changes their mind after talking it out.
I know.
I right out of the gate,
I was like,
no brainer.
I'll take 65 grand a year in the NFL package and I'll be an absolute fucking
nobody and I'll rub it out to internet porn before I would go back into medieval
fucking times with scurvy,
gang green,
the blackball scurvy I wouldn't have,
cause I'd be a king.
I'd have plenty of fucking vitamins.
Steven,
is that what it is?
No vitamin seasonal fruit in your diet or some shit?
Um,
yeah,
fuck all that.
And then everybody come in to try to fucking kill me.
And then just the shit I would have to do to stay in power,
putting people in iron maidens and stretching them out.
I am like,
I don't want to hurt people.
You know?
And then if you're a cool king,
right?
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
they call you fucking Lord snowflake.
They,
we all these liberal fucking,
everybody would think they could get over on you.
Right.
And then you just have to stick someone in the belly of the beast.
You know,
I think about that fucking all the time meant like out of all those things,
the iron maiden,
they slam it shut.
You're dead.
You know,
the rack is fucking brutal.
the rack,
they actually,
they thought it's stretched in,
broke you,
you're a Toyota tendons and stuff.
When it actually did was it broke your bones by stretching to the point that
they cracked at me.
Just fucking insane.
Human beings are so fucking horrible.
It's,
it's,
it's not even like he came,
you can't wrap your head around it,
but the belly of the beast,
you know what I mean?
[inaudible] being in the belly of the beast,
they would actually have like some giant looking bowl thing
made out of cast iron or something and they would put you in there,
close it and enlight a fire underneath and basically cook you alive.
And the amount of times I thought of what I would do
if I was in there,
I would just slam my fucking head.
I would fuck I do the million dollar baby.
I would bite through my fucking time,
but it,
but to actually fucking,
you know,
hot,
it'd have to be before I could actually have the balls to do that.
Um,
is there a way to just like,
you know,
you just rip your own throat out?
I would literally,
I would try to fucking puncture my neck and bleed out.
That's what I would try to do.
Um,
but they probably put you in their butt ass naked with you for all tied up and
shit.
I mean,
just fucking brutal.
So it's not even a question dude.
65 grand of fucking year in the present,
you know,
buy,
dress like Albert Einstein,
same fucking clothes every day except to be more than Malcolm Young Wardrobe,
breast,
his soul.
Do you know,
I've been,
you know,
going through a lot of shit here and I actually found this Malcolm Young,
uh,
like action figure thing that I have not action figure.
It's like it's,
but I bought the thing,
I never assembled it cause you had to came from somewhere in Asia,
you know,
Angus didn't get any money on it and you fucking,
uh,
you gotta glue his feet to the fucking base and a,
I've been meaning to go over to one of these fucking mom and pop department
stores,
you know,
fuck on depo.
I mean,
anytime like you want to talk about someone who gets act like a king over this,
you can actually find somebody on the floor.
They can,
that doesn't have 20 people like running after them.
You know,
like when the dog whisperer goes over the hill and he's got $20 about 20 kids
behind them or dogs behind that.
That's what the fucking home Depot's like.
So anyways,
yeah,
I would take 65 grand a year.
Great question though.
Great questions.
Uh,
great.
Um,
I hope that gate,
I,
it's gonna work out for you,
buddy.
All right.
If you want,
you got to tell somebody first dates tamed by yourself.
Uh,
I've always wanted a Lamborghini,
you know,
Jesus.
What kind of woman would that attract?
Uh,
I don't know,
but that's your dilemma,
buddy.
Good luck with it.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on,
yeah.
Thursday.